thanks for joining us America we're glad
you're here Shawn's with us in Montana
hey Shawn how are you
well you're so cool better than I
deserve what's up well let me just lay
down the situation real quick and I'll
get to the question if that's okay okay
president laying the job I have I make
like twenty two three a year me and my
wife have nine thousand three hundred
and forty two dollars and that mm-hm
what do you do I'm a direct care
professional you're a what direct care
so I take care of people who are
developmentally disabled and work on
behavioral stuff with them and you make
twenty two thousand dollars a year yep
okay so yeah basically I have an
opportunity to relocate from where I am
in Montana back to Austin which is where
I'm from
mm-hmm and the single job would double
my income mm-hmm that in doing so I
would not be bringing my family with me
at first and have the opportunity to
stay rent-free with my father and work
mm-hmm why would your family not go with
you
affordability I can't afford to move
them I mean we don't even have a
foundation two thousand dollars to start
paying off our dad I mean right now I'm
dealing with like negative cash flow
right does your wife work outside the
home no if you care I got four kids your
four kids okay yep all right and do you
own a home oh we're at okay and so
basically you can loan your furniture
into a u-haul and pull it across the
country and be in Boston and get an
apartment right
well in the long haul yes but short term
I would buy a plane ticket
why not load your wife up and go I
wouldn't have the money to put them in
an apartment uh-huh okay so you're going
to be making twice as much though so how
quickly would you be moving them uh well
she's pregnant with our fifth so the
thought process would be in the summer
probably August after the birth no I'm
not doing that
I'm not leaving my pregnant wife and
four kids halfway around the dadgum
world and go live with your dad not a
chance I'm loading her up and moving
dude as your Kenny of your family help
you a little bit I mean it won't cost
much to get moved
maybe the employer would give the new
employer would give you an advance to
get you moved into your new apartment
there's a possibility with that yeah you
need to load up your family and get out
of there
but you know not being with your
pregnant wife while she's carrying what
your fifth child you're in Boston and
she's in Montana
dude that is not okay I mean you're not
in the military you're not you're not
required to be separated like that
you're just making bad choices now you
need to fit you need to scrape together
a few dollars and go deliver some pizzas
or something and for a month and pile up
you know thousand fifteen hundred bucks
and get you a u-haul and get your butt
in gear and roll on over to Boston and
take that job or move in with your dad
for a month with the whole dadgum crew
over there if you can something like
that I mean you need to find a different
way but this idea you're gonna delay
bringing your whole family and while
your wife is kidding no no no that's not
gonna work out for you that's gonna end
poorly I'm gonna sure you hey thanks for
calling in hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
now
[Applause]
[Music]